it's that time of the month again the
PlayStation Plus games for September
2016 have been announced this month is
an absolute cracker containing six games
- for the ps4 - for the ps3 and 2 for
the Vita as well
we have discovery action role-playing
games a side scroller a few platformers
and an interactive novel this month
let's start things up with the big guns
on ps4 journey is the pick of the bunch
this time round and is an absolutely
phenomenal game first released in 2012
this shot that captivating game has a
single goal reach the angelic light a
top of the mountain over yonder you can
stumble across other players in the game
but you can't control who those players
are and you can't really communicate
with them other than the occasional
tweet and I don't mean on Twitter I
really don't want to spoil this game for
you as it is so shot so I beg you and
plead with you play this one it's an
awesome two or three hours next up is
the logs of the Fallen first released in
2014
this is a daxo less can counter in which
you will die a lot the loot chests and
customizable elements resemble the Adler
the challenge is growing difficulty and
the bosses do push you to think pass
button bashing your way to godhood the
Metacritic score is surprisingly low at
68 but GameSpot gave it an overall 8 out
of 10 so make your own mind up over to
the ps3 for our first offering and it's
Prince of Persia The Forgotten Sands and
noir this has nothing to do with the g8
Gyllenhaal film the game is based around
the ability to reverse time as your
acrobatically platform through each
level as the game ramps up the ability
to freeze walls and rebuild former
structures helps the game stand apart
from its predecessors and overall it's a
fun game which helps you reminisce about
yesteryear current metacritic score is
75 out of 100 the next offering on ps3
is datura an intriguing and well
presented game which is ultimately let
down by its gameplay which is
infuriating and at best muddled the
storyline is interesting but I don't
recommend playing this one over to the
PS Vita for Badlands which in fact is a
cross play game so if you don't have a
Vita you drop the S bar or ps3 badland
is essentially a mobile phone game which
plays by local rook
it's a super simple obstacle course
which is extremely repetitive but for a
5-minute John this is a perfect game to
pick finally amnesia memories rounds out
this month's options this one is a
visual novel in which you participate in
four storylines if storylines are
getting to know your character our key
elements when you play games this one is
for you
push Square gave this one a massive 8
out of 10 so that's it what do you think
of this month's offerings sound off
below please consider subscribing if
this has been a few seer and help our
tiny channel grow
I've been Adam this is Playstation
grenade I'll see you next time